what we got here in the GOP Primary went
down to two we are just one day away
from the high stakes Republican primary
in New Hampshire all eyes on Donald
Trump and Nikki Haley they are the last
two candidates standing after a massive
shakeup in the race Florida Governor
Ronda santis dropping out and endorsing
the former president it's clear to me
that a majority of Republican primary
voters want to give Donald Trump another
chance Trump is superior to the current
incumbit Joe Biden that is clear I
signed a pledge to support the
Republican nominee and I will honor that
pledge so who is going to come out on
top tomorrow the latest polls from New
Hampshire show Trump is ahead by nearly
20 points the former president getting
57% of the vote when compared to 38%
Nikki Haley gets and here's president
Trump sounding off on the race somebody
said what are you going to do with the
name to sanct demonius I said that name
is officially retired as of this moment
we are retiring that name so that's
water under the bridge now between
totally as far as I'm concerned look he
endorsement I would say that with Nikki
I have haven't done anything I I'm very
upset with her she said I would never
run he was a great president I would he
she worked for me like for two and a
half years and she was okay not great
she was okay but she said to everybody
in fact when she left I would never run
against the president and Nikki Haley
might be banking on some Democrats and
independents to save the day according
to a new report from Politico they say
that a handful of left-leaning groups
have popped up across New Hampshire with
the goal of persuading the state's
Undeclared voter
who make up 42% of the voting population
and are eligible to vote in either
party's primary to back Haley the former
South Carolina governor hitting the
trail hard ramping up her attacks on
trump it is a fact that you decline over
time it is a fact that you slow down and
what I'm saying is the country is in
disarray the world is on fire we need
somebody who's going to be at the top of
their game you've got Donald Trump in a
courtroom
today and you've got him and Joe Biden
giving us more of the same they are both
talking about griev es of the past
vendettas and their investigations we
need a new generational conservative
leader that's going to be focused on how
we're going to get America back on track
for our
kids uh Jesse Waters here in New
Hampshire uh with me and then our great
crew there in New York so it's going to
be a good five Jesse let me start with
you Nikki Haley had said for a long time
she wanted to get this to a two-person
race she did that uh is it in time for
her to make a big dent tomorrow night
well I just want to know what gutfeld's
wearing he a shacket he looks like he's
in New Hampshire and I'm in Manhattan I
found it in your
closet stay out of my closet
Gutfeld it's just so different to see
these two men Biden you have if you
cross him he'll indict you or deny you
Secret Service protection but if you
cross Trump it's about honor and he
lives by a different code where if he
does something for you and you are
perceived as disloyal perhaps you've
been appointed to a cabinet position or
been endorsed and gotten the
gubernatorial ship because of his
endorsement you're not allowed to run
against him and so then you'll get a
nickname but all of a sudden if you drop
out an endorse and the nickname's over
and I would assume and you know Jessica
that I never make predictions anymore
but just for the sake of argument if
Nikki does not win and eventually does
have to suspend and endorse I'm sure
bird brain will be retired and
everything can come together and we can
get it together that's not a book plug
they just happened to say that um but
this is barbaric this politics stuff and
Nikki also has to be careful because she
can't be too vicious and savagely attack
the president as being mentally
incapacitated just the way Democrats
wouldn't do that to Joe Biden or go
after Hunter because you don't want to
hand the other side too much ammo where
you wound them so drastically that they
end up li imping into the general so I'm
not telling her how to run her campaign
but I am so she just has to calculate
what's best for her and see Over the
Horizon and see what's good for the
party as a whole long term Jorge Janine
what's on your mind today well you know
I think it's interesting that Nikki haly
comes out and she says you know we need
someone who's really on top of their
game when she was the one who was asked
what was the cause of the Civil War and
she floundered that so badly I mean a
third grader could have answered it
better better than she did and you know
she may have a false sense of confidence
now given that the New Hampshire primary
uh involves independent voters who make
up 40% of the electorate and they can
vote for either major Party candidate so
it's in their interest to vote for Nikki
so that Trump doesn't look as strong
because Trump really is the one that
they don't want to run against and you
know she can drag out uh Judge Judy but
there are other judges who don't think
she's necessarily the best candidate but
having said all that I think Nikki's
days are coming to an end um if she uh
if Trump beats her in double digits then
she's out of New Hampshire because she
goes to South Carolina she can't even
win in her own state where she was the
governor you've got uh Tim Scott the
senator you've got Nancy Ma you got the
governor now the lieutenant governor
everyone in South Carolina is supporting
Donald Trump so she can talk about how
this is two-person race when it was a
three-person race but the truth is that
um I I don't think she's got a lot of
support going forward I do want to
mention one thing about Donald Trump and
I was very impressed the way he handled
uh Ronda santz stepping out of the race
you know it was almost like for all the
noise it was a whisper that DeSantis
just kind of left and and I thought
Trump was very nice to him but more
importantly I was impressed with the
fact that Donald Trump former president
Trump talked about Casey santis and he
gave her Kudos he said she worked very
hard she's a lovely woman and I mean I
kind of like that you know let's come
together all of us and let's just say
this uh if he gets to 60 uh it's over
for her she's out she's
gone got F in the shacket what are you
thinking yeah I just want to
congratulate Jessica on a successful
transition did you call me did you call
me
Jessica
I think he was talking about Jessica
who's somewhere in here um yeah I saw
her earlier yeah all right all right um
you know I I want to look I I want to
look back at like at Rona santis because
I think you know even though the
campaign wasn't the best he actually did
a great job and he did a great service
he basically stress tested Trump and
remove the wh ifs from 2024 you know you
have the you have the never trumpers and
the n sers who said you know if only we
had a competent alternative right if we
have a normal candidate you know as an
option to Trump all we want is an
alternative to Trump well you got it you
got the best damn governor in the
country and it didn't make a dent and it
is pretty impressive Des santis just
reeks of confidence he succeeds wherever
he goes and yet it still didn't happen
and it's because it's probably not the
right time for him and it's the right
time again for trump it feels inevitable
uh and despite all the obstacles of the
media and the law fair and the compet
and the competitors Trump's still like
breezing to the Finish Line I have a
metaphor uh so many people are pushing
electric vehicles on the American public
but the American public still prefers
the gas guzzler doesn't make the EVS bad
it just means that the EVS this isn't
their time yet and so so Trump is
basically he's like a red white and blue
10 ton big rig blaring Freebird as it
rolls over every woke Prius in its path
you know DeSantis is just a great car
but he'll be needed later just not right
now I like the metaphor very much J your
political analysis says we're down to
two candidates in New Hampshire the last
time we were here there were so many in
2016 think there are still eight left in
the race there's no doubt about it good
to be back around the table even even in
this table we got going here today A
couple things New Hampshire has been a
place where you get surprises sometimes
I mean Danny you recall I think we
talked about it a week or so ago uh
mcain beat W uh in New Hampshire after W
had won Iowa Hart beat Mandel uh Hillary
Clinton beat Obama and even Trump back
in 16 beat Cruz after Cruz had won Iowa
so you don't you don't quite know and
it'd be interesting to see they have
those rules up there where Democrats can
vote in Republican primaries and vice
versa so we'll see what happens but the
polling data has been pretty consistent
um and been pretty accurate uh it looks
like the president at 15 or former
president 15 20 points ahead is
interesting uh it looks like he may hold
it I I I slightly differ with with Greg
on the santis and N Go I don't disagree
with his competence I don't disagree
with the fact that I would have
campaigned different he's making faces
at me I would have been out have
campaign differently if I were him um
but for whatever reason it didn't work
and you have to wonder if in four years
it will work maybe it will maybe maybe
the car analogy is is the exact right
one but he reminds me of of of you know
we have these candidates every four
years and some most of the time on the
Republican side we had Scott Walker a
year when he was supposed to be
unbeatable or invincible and just it
didn't it didn't happen Donald Trump
whatever you want to say about him
democrat or republican is is one of the
best political athletes uh that we've
seen in in in in any era uh and he has
shown that again I again I come back to
how he was so cons Ator and magnanimous
the night he won in Iowa the question
came out again as he watched the santis
as we watched the santis get out the
race and I thought the santis is exit
from the race his speech was the best
speech I'd heard him give during the
campaign uh and campaigns are funny um
you know you can want to go on but if
you can't raise money you think you're
going to be threaten or threaten your
imperil your chances to raise money
going forward you get out of these races
uh we're about to I think come tomorrow
night uh see the beginning of the
longest presidential campaign in the
history of the country because I think
president Trump will win tomorrow Harold
can I ask you something real quick um
before we go to break uh what is Wall
Street thinking right now about these
two candidates Biden and Trump well I
read in I don't I can't speak for all
them but I saw where Nikki Haley still
has a fundraiser planned by some of the
uh the great minds on on on the street
and some of the great financiers uh I
think early next week uh but if she
doesn't do well I think you're going to
hear there's going to be a lot of
pressure for her to do what Dan santis
did which is to get out Dana can I ask
you a question what are what's the
thinking on on Sesame
Street you're asking me yeah well um I
wasn't able to go there today but I'm
really looking forward to it tomorrow
okay cigg can I ask you a question yes
what's the thinking on Brokeback
Mountain what do you mean we got to go I
think we should keep it going anyway hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now